shortly after four o'clock this morning
i spoke to president zielenski of
ukraine as the first missiles struck his
beautiful and innocent country and its
brave people and i assured him of the
unwavering support
of the united kingdom
earlier today
president putin delivered another
televised address and offered the absurd
pretext that he sought the
demilitarization
and de-nazification
of ukraine
in fact he is hurling the might of his
military machine against a free and
peaceful neighbor in breach of his own
explicit pledge and every principle of
civilized behavior between states
spurning the best efforts of this
country and our allies to avoid
bloodshed
for this putin
will stand condemned in the eyes of the
world and of history
he will never be able to cleanse the
blood of ukraine from his hands
and although the uk and our allies tried
every avenue for diplomacy until the
final hour i'm driven to conclude that
putin was always determined to attack
his neighbor no matter what we did
now we see him
for what he is
a blood-stained aggressor who believes
in imperial conquest
i am proud that britain did everything
within our power to help ukraine prepare
for this onslaught and we will do our
utmost to offer more help as our brave
friends defend their homeland
now
we have a clear mission
diplomatically
politically
economically
and eventually
militarily
this hideous and barbarous venture of
vladimir putin must end in failure
at the g7 meeting this afternoon we
agreed to work in unity to maximize the
economic price that putin will pay for
his aggression and this
must include
ending europe's collective dependence on
russian oil and gas
that has served to empower putin for too
long so i i welcomed again chancellor
schultz's excellent decision to halt the
certification of nordstrom 2.
mr speaker countries that together
comprise about half the world economy
are now engaged in maximizing pressure
economic pressure on one that makes up a
mere two percent for our part today the
uk is announcing the largest and most
severe package of economic sanctions
that russia has ever seen
with new financial measures we're taking
new powers to target russian finance in
addition to the banks we've already
sanctioned this week today in concert
with the united states we are imposing a
full asset freeze on vtb
more broadly these powers will enable us
totally to exclude russian banks from
the uk financial system which is of
course by far the largest in europe
stopping them from accessing sterling
and clearing payments through the uk
and with around half of russia's trade
currently in u.s dollars and sterling
i'm pleased to tell the house that the
united states is taking similar measures
these powers will also enable us to ban
russian state and private companies from
raising funds in the uk
banning dealing with their securities
and making loans to them
we will limit the amount of money that
russian nationals will be able to
deposit in their uk bank accounts
and sanctions will also be applied to
belarus for its role in the assault on
ukraine
[Music]
overall we'll we'll be imposing asset
freezes on more than 100
new entities and individuals on top of
the hundreds that we've already
announced
this includes all the major
manufacturers that support putin's war
machine
furthermore
we are also banning
aeroflot from the uk
next on top of these financial measures
and in full concert with the united
states and the eu
we will introduce new trade restrictions
and
stringent export controls similar to
those that they in the u.s are
implementing we will bring forward new
legislation
to ban the export of all dual use items
to russia
including a range of high-end and
critical technological equipment and
components in sectors
including electronics telecommunications
and aerospace
legislation to implement this will be
laid early next week
these trade sanctions will constrain
russia's military industrial and
technological capabilities for years to
come